hello and welcome to sweep like em
western yeah who is a tough opponent
when so hard time to decide what I
should do it at this position okay start
going with h3 good I came okay so i made
this mistake a number of times not
playing to five now right I should do
the five though I can play this
unpunished I really should do it okay um
can take or 27 Queen dissemble I guess
48
ok let's see him interesting question i
have a couple of options I can do d for
interesting move actually I don't play
that too often in those structures but
it could be interested in here just gain
space and look at the a to pawn it I
think it's really hanging ok SC for
maybe one to cut it off but he was he
felt irritated enough let's aim to lend
it some protection ok before gaining
some space I would like to somehow play
on the knight to e7 and go see five if
this would be really nice can I do that
I maybe night age for mm-hmm stumbled
right into that idea but anyway 97 I
have some okay here he might have bishop
age 6 no not not might he does have it
ok so go back
who
hmm it looks very threatening
I don't see a direct threat I really
don't probably my own problem I should
see it but I don't see it my dears ago
f5 if he allows me to do it
I push page six Quincy 30 I blind I'm
totally blind idiot right this is the
easiest thing ever to see and I don't
see it remarkable yeah that was the idea
it wasn't difficult to see oh my okay
maybe this for Queen takes a g6 keeping
things kind of closed at least
currently still has that ugly bishop on
b1 ok ok ok ok I think I have to take 9
s6 check pawn takes 2 327 kingi tool I
can go where I am
Queen h3 is my idea here to make it
difficult for that if he has to go
cringy to I'm fine I mean ever pawn down
but that's not a problem check okay so
hmm hmm that I played really really bad
really badly
follow along it wasn't necessary at all
to get the Brewers bishop in this
position it should have been the other
way robot I could have always taken on
c3 it would have been a very simple way
of activating my bishop time warning
that's how to save I can draw this from
the not what i was thinking always as a
rope trade ever can draw afternoon trade
and probably i can't
check
I think it's draw objectively but of
course it's got 20 seconds check this is
dead wrong I still think it's wrong to
be honest even though I'm a couple of
points down moving on time you know what
a deal black forfeits one time I was a
very bad game I mean especially now I
mean after after the Queen trade this
position is completely fine I shouldn't
even suffer him what did i do here and
some other moves on flights okay the
idea of course it was all my old phone
that i blundered into this special page
6 stuff but okay thing is there's
nothing going on him check this position
I just have to just have to play
correctly him but what I did there was
just incredibly stupid so how to how to
play it correctly this yeah I know you
went with damn i know it's it's already
too late the idea is to take you and
goes with some before
let my bishop is actually active but I
did get that in I simply didn't this one
maybe
that could be the right right way to do
it I don't understand that the engine
here but ok the computer you can forget
about in this position it doesn't
understand the pollution here it doesn't
understand the position because this has
fortress typed character and this is
where you can throw the engine out of
the window for example the engines
thinks this is better for Wyatt which is
which is just wrong I just put the
bishop on d6 and stay for the rest of
the game will never lose or it has no
way of getting any passport there's just
nothing at all and then draw any
opposite color bishop ending I just have
to make get my bishop active and I
simply as simply ignore simply didn't
see that coming here Bishop g5 and ce4 i
was thinking i play see for myself but
this is ridiculous he gets this in and
now I'm in trouble and now this is too
late this is this is too late now he
just stays there he never takes and this
was bad and now I'm standing here yeah
it's just purely purely passive chanting
I still think it's a draw to do instead
maybe I'm wrong man but I think I think
why shouldn't should win and this is a
definite draw but ok ahead of time here
it was I was a pre move this is this is
of course and much easier after that
whoo nothing absolutely nothing does it
even get an a porn but even this I think
is strong
how is he supposed to get anywhere here
I don't I don't see it no it's just a
drawing what can you do but ok had no
time ok thanks for watching